People keep asking me, how do you move a
real object using geometry nodes? And
the answer is pretty simple. Triangle
parenting. So in this case, the camera
is parented to this triangle. And the
triangle moves and it just works
perfectly. So let's get this set up. So
let's add in a new object like a camera.
And let's add in our triangle, which in
this case will be a circle. We'll set
the vertices to be three. And we'll go
and fill in the face using F. Now we can
see we have a triangle. So, let's parent
the camera to the triangle. And that's
pretty simple. We just press Ctrl P and
set the parenting to vertex triangle
mode. Now, if we do this and move the
triangle in edit mode, we can see that
the location and rotation work. But
unfortunately, the scale doesn't work.
So, if you need that, uh, you're kind of
out of luck. So, with this, we can now
move this triangle and it'll just work.
I also recommend just, you know, moving
the camera so that it is facing the
right direction. And we can go and scale
down the triangle to make it, you know,
invisible. But you could always just
eliminate it in the render option. So
let's go and move this triangle to
match, I don't know, some instances
which we have conveniently placed right
over here. So let's go and use a
transform geometry node. And right here,
we can go and move the triangle however
we want using this. But in this case,
I'm going to use the matrix option. So
I'm going to drag our instances into
here. then use a sample index node to go
and sample the instances transform
matrix and we'll go and put this onto
the object. So we'll go and use the
instance transform just like that and
we'll go and plug this into here. So and
also remember to set it to relative and
now we can see that this real object
this real camera is being moved to match
a geometry nodes driven object. So we
can see that that works out quite well.
And also just to verify, we can go and
look inside the camera and we can see it
is moving around and having a wonderful
time. So, yep, that's how you go and
move real objects using geometry nodes.
I hope you like these shorter tutorials.
I hope they are useful and I will see
you next time. Have a good one.